thank you can you expand on the Holy
Spirit as distinct from Jesus Christ and
God within the Trinity yes I'll try
that's what it takes two hundred pages
in the book to try to unravel but let me
just say a few little good things I hope
all right remember I said the Holy
Spirit the the metaphor is used are
always dynamic metaphors moving
metaphors flow metaphors the Holy Spirit
is like the glue the goodness glue I
call it in my book immortal demon that
connects everything it keeps everything
connected really the state of sin and it
is a state more than an action is when
you disconnect we know this from mass
murderers they're always disconnected
people you know and we were told of it
you were told like me that our job was
to be correct no your job is to be
connected that's all just stay connect
state if in the beginning was the
relationship you will know God as long
as you stay in relationship with the
flower in front of you with the blue sky
above you with your wife with your
children don't disconnect when you
disconnect you're in the state of sin
and at that point you will end up doing
a lot of stupid things when you do
actions that we would call sinful let's
just be very traditional right I would
be willing to bet if I could be your
spiritual director or your confessor at
that moment when you did something
really stupid you were unconscious you
were when your conscious you'll always
love you'll always love when you're
unconscious you will do cruel things
rude things deceitful things lustful
things
you're always unconscious so I hope this
helps you understand that the spirit and
I said it real quickly the spirit and
consciousness for me or the same thing
and love you can use those three words
interchangeably interchangeably and I
can prove that with Orthodox theology
right they're the same thing
so Jesus is the physical manifestation
you always have to deal with physicality
when the word became flesh so that's why
in the end there will only be Christ
loving himself when the whole physical
universe recognizes itself in one
another when all of you so that's why in
the Christian world we rightly say we
are the body of Christ yeah that's
correct
and then as you so beautifully did this
morning I was able to celebrate with two
of your Eucharist Agustin says this so
well we feed you the body of Christ
so this mystery of Incarnation jut
doesn't just move to the personal level
it moves to the elemental level
symbolize in bread and wine that even
the elemental universe is the body of
Christ oh my god I know you're gonna
call me a pantheist no that's
Christianity it's Christianity that's
Incarnation illegitimate is rightly
called pan and theism God in all things
not God is all things so makes that
distinction that'll please your pastors
all right I'm not teaching pantheism but
I am saying what the gospel clearly
proclaims that God is in all things so
Christ is always the mystery of
physicality in flesh meant embodiment
materiality the Spirit is the goodness
glue that keeps everything connected the
father is the transpersonal source out
of which all this love flows and return
so that's the best I can do for now